et si pour les fêtes cette année vous
offriez une bouteille 100 % ivelinoise
pour l'occasion je vous propose de
découvrir le domaine de la bouche du roi
situé à d'Avron dans la plaine de
[Musique]
Versailles c'est en 1588 que des
someliers investissent le domaine
l'objectif faire rayonner l'art de vivre
ivelinois d'abord dégusté à Versailles
le vin s'exporte peu à peu reconnu dans
le monde entier le nom de domaine la B
du roi est un clin d'œil au roi de
France et au passé viticol de la région
car figurez-vous qu'au 18e siècle l'île
de France était considéré comme la plus
grande région viticole de l'Hexagone
riche de cet héritage avec 19 parcelles
le domaine propose une collection de
sépages anciens et six grands sépages
français alors avis aux amateurs ou aux
passionnés de vin le prix moyen pour une
bouteille est de 27 € de quoi soutenir
l'artisanat tout en faisant plaisir à
vos
proches